نذهب الان الى ايران قضيه تسميمه طالبات
المدارس هناك تتفاقم واكثر من الف طالبه
تسممت بغاز ان تو والسلطات الايرانيه حتى
اللحظه لم تعلن اعتقال اي احد على خلفيه
هذه الحوادث حوادث التصميم نشطؤوا
ايرانيون يؤكدون انها متعمده وتاتي في
اطار خلق ازمه المجتمعيه لتفقد قضيه
الاحتجاجات زخمها وحرف الانتباه عن
الاحتجاجات الحاصله ضد النظام الايراني
منذ سبتمبر واليوم ايضا مشاهدينا شهدت
مدرسه في العاصمه طهران تسمما جديدا
واولياء الامور يؤكدون اطلاق نوع من
الرذاذ في المدرسه على بناتهم هجمات السم
هذه تشمل حتى اليوم نحو خمس مدن على الاقل
في ايران مستهدفه اكثر من 30 مدرسه مما
دفع الاباء لاخراج بناتهم من المدارس حيث
بلغ تسميم وطالبات المدارس في ايران شهره
الخامس والتي بدات حالته بالظهور في شهر
نوفمبر الماضي بمدينه قم اي بعد شهر من
الاحتجاجات على النظام وزاره الصحه
الايرانيه قالت ان السمه خفيف مشدده على
ان التحقيق فيما حدث للفتيات من تسمم ليس
من اختصاصها بل وانها ليست مسؤوله عن
الادلاء بتصريحات حول ما اذا كان الحادث
متعمدا ام اما مسؤولوه النظام فاتهموا من
قالوا انه عدو خارجيه يتدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه
وتحرك مندسيها هناك وفقه وصفهم ايرانيون
معارضون مشاهدينا يرون ان ما يحدث هو
تقليد ممنهج لسلوك بوكو حرام في نيجيريا
وطالبان في افغانستان من ترويع للاهالي
للتوقف عن ارسال بناتهم الى المدرسه
[موسيقى]